hey what's up I'm even I'm here to do a
Google autocomplete interview thank you
scaredy's is what what is Eve's favorite
word probably can I say that it's a
good work
where is Eve's clothing line I sold it
what what is Eve's best hairstyle she's
ever worn well at the moment I'm feeling
this situation right here what is each
biggest influence ah that's a good
question
whenever I write I write about things
that have gone on in my life or with
someone in my life yeah just life in
reality is Eve British as you can tell
from my horrible British accent no I'm
from Philly I'm a Philly girl
it is IVA feminist possibly possibly I
don't know I don't put titles on myself
it is a really short no I am tall I'm
about five six and a half five seven
five seven
that's not short but yeah is 'if friends
with wind stuff on e yeah me and winter
cool if I see her out and we you know
it's all love I love when she's one of
my favorite people is Eve funny
obviously no I try to be does eat does
Eve have piercings I do actually my ears
are pierced I've had others other places
that I've gotten rid of I actually I'm
thinking about some new ones does Eve
wear glasses I do actually wear glasses
does Eve speak another language I
pretend I can but honestly I can't but
that is a challenge to myself this year
I plan on learning French this year does
Eve have a nickname family members call
me Evie some people call me e friends
call me E does Eve believe in aliens
I do y'all we can't be here by ourselves
thank you